[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All right.
I'm going to get started.
This is Lecture 23, about
policy with behavioral agents,
the last lecture of 14.13,
for better or worse.
OK.
So what's the plan for today?
We're going to talk
about paternalism,
what is paternalism,
reasons for paternalism,
why it might be popular or not.
We're going to talk about
the specific example of what
was coined as
libertarian paternalism.
I'll explain more, which
is the Save More Tomorrow
plan, what's good about
this specific example.
And we'll discuss that.
And finally, we'll talk
about some market solutions.
Often one solution
that's often mentioned
is to say, well,
why can't the market
solve these kinds of issues.
And we're going to talk
about why that may or may not
be a good idea.
So then, let me
just ask very simply
to start with, from
your classes that you've
taken in economics
and otherwise,
what are some reasons
for government policies?
And it doesn't mean
that you necessarily
endorse those reasons.
But what are the reasons
why the government, why
we might want the
government to engage
in an economic or other sort
of of government policies?
So one reason might be
that people don't quite
know what's good for them.
And so we can potentially
help them by doing so.
That's, of course, the reason--
that's, of course, what we're
going to talk about today.
Let me rephrase my question.
In neoclassical economics, what
are reasons for the government
to engage?
The behavioral ones
of course, we're
going to call internalities,
which is essentially people
must optimize in certain ways.
But what are the
neoclassical reasons
for the government to engage?
So this would be things
like externalities.
This could be individuals
causing externalities.
Externalities, essentially,
is a fancy word
for people causing some positive
or negative effects on others
that they might not be
able to internalize.
This could be smokers or
individuals doing that.
Like, for example, smoking might
cause health effects on others.
Could be also farms
polluting the environment
or polluting water or some
other resources of other people
polluting like--
otherwise the air, and
so on, and so forth,
which might be bad
for others' health.
And to the extent that
the firm or others are not
sort of taking
that into account,
that will lead to socially
sub optimal outcomes.
Now the government would
say, well, let's tax that.
Because we want to
make sure that people
are taking into account
these externalities.
And with the optimal
tax schedule,
potentially, these can get back
to the [INAUDIBLE] potentially.
So usually the terms that look
like free markets, et cetera,
they essentially
will-- the free market
will achieve that things are
efficient and potentially
under some conditions.
But what the market will
not typically achieve
is some form of equity.
And to the extent that we
are interested in that,
you might want to engage in
social security, insurance
program, unemployment insurance,
and so on, and so forth.
So if you have lots
of competition,
the prices will fall down
to often marginal costs.
And that's good for consumers
because stuff is cheap.
It could [INAUDIBLE]
only one firm,
the firm, the monopolist
in the [INAUDIBLE] case,
the monopolist will charge
above a marginal cost.
So prices will be higher,
fewer things will be sold,
and people will be
less happy about that.
And then there's sort of this
antitrust in 1420, as you say,
exactly Nancy Rose and
others are working on
that, antitrust
commissions, et cetera,
trying to essentially
make sure there's
sufficient
computation in markets
because we think that's
good for welfare.
So there's other sort
of market failures.
For example, public
goods, parts, and so on,
the government might
want to provide that.
Because in general, people
might under-provide that.
Could be also other
things, like information,
[INAUDIBLE] information, tend
to fail, reason being that,
when I come up
with an idea that's
useful for a lot of
people, I might not
be able to internalize
the rents from that
if I'm under investing,
therefore, in R&D, and so on.
So now I think we have all
the things I have on my list.
There's macroeconomic policy,
as Tom just mentioned.
The Federal Reserve might try
to [INAUDIBLE] its interest rate
and fiscal stimulus.
Competition policy, that's
what Even just mentioned.
Then there's just
redistribution,
social insurance.
I think that's what Justin
said on unemployment insurance,
social security, and so on.
And then there might
be externality.
That's what Natalie
said, particular taxes
and other sort of market
failures, such as innovation.
That's what Jose, as well, said.
What we're going to focus on now
is none of these things which,
and that's getting
back to what we
said at the very beginning,
which is the internalities.
So that's not a traditional
way for governments to engage.
And if you went back, like, 20
years from now, the government,
there would be no such urge
to use such considerations.
But more recently,
in part, perhaps,
as a consequence of the rise
of behavioral economics,
people are much more interested
now in internalities.
So what are internalities?
It's essentially sort of
similar to [INAUDIBLE]..
The coin is very similar.
Instead of causing damage or
not internalizing sufficiently
effects on other
people, this is now
effects on your future
self, essentially.
So that the consumer is not
fully [INAUDIBLE] the costs
and/or benefits she imposes
on her future potential self.
And if the government
is sort of now
confident that that's the case,
well, then, the government
might want to intervene.
Now what's paternalism?
Paternalism is essentially
a version of that.
There's a very
convoluted definition
by the Merriam-Webster
dictionary, which
I'm not going to read to you.
But it is one definition.
And there's a better one
from David Laibson, which
is "An attempt to influence
or control people's
conduct for their own good.
In other words, when the
motivation for the intervention
is not about externalities."
So it's to say if
we try to affect
people's behavior
for their own good
in some way, that sort of
assumes, of course, that people
are not fully optimizing in
certain ways, not when it comes
to their effects on
others, [INAUDIBLE]
the effects on
themselves, [INAUDIBLE]..
OK?
[INAUDIBLE]
There was a question?
Now when is
paternalism warranted?
Because [INAUDIBLE] going
through the list of topics
that we discussed in the class.
And it's important to understand
that not all of these topics
are, in fact,
warranting intervention.
For example, if you think people
have certain risk preferences,
reference-dependent preferences,
or social preferences,
that's not a bias or
problem that we need to fix.
People care about others.
And that's just the way their
utility function is like.
And then you show that people
can optimize accordingly.
That's not necessarily
a bias or a problem.
Of course, if there's problems
with self-control, problems
with people at [INAUDIBLE]
inconsistent preferences,
we might want to help people.
That assumes, of course,
that we know which self
is the one we want to support.
There's lots of
space here, when we
think about
non-standard beliefs,
for people to make mistakes, or
for our governments and others
to intervene.
This would be limited attention,
also things like memory,
like, people just forget stuff.
Learning failure is where people
have just wrong information.
Overoptimism, overconfidence,
projection, and attribution
bias, these are all
essentially people that
make mistakes in some ways.
And to the extent that
they make mistakes,
we might want to intervene.
Importantly, we
discussed this already,
motivated beliefs are
not necessarily a reason,
or going to be very
careful with that.
That is, as we said previously
when we talked about health
issues, for example.
So if somebody does not
want to know their health
status because they want to feel
happy or make themselves think
that they are happy, and
they don't want to know that,
because they want to have
a few years of their lives
in which they think can
[INAUDIBLE] themselves
into thinking they're
happy, healthy and happy,
it's not obvious that
they're making a mistake.
In a sense, they could
be making a mistake.
Because potentially, there could
be health investments or health
behaviors that they could engage
in to improve their behavior.
But it could also
just be that, look,
there's actually
not much one can do.
And so now, if we
intervene, we might actually
make things worse.
Because they're somebody
who actually doesn't even
want to know what's going on.
Often, that's actually the case.
But instead of
just flagging that
for motivated beliefs,
when people derive utility
from beliefs, things
get tricky quite easily.
And then we talked about
non-standard decision-making,
gender discrimination.
There's a clear case
for intervention
if people don't get treated
the right way, as they should,
or any other discrimination.
And then we talked about
these other aspects here.
Of course, then, defaults,
frames, and hudges
are not necessarily
reasons to intervene.
These are more like instruments
that we can use to intervene.
You can set defaults,
or frames, or nudges
in certain ways that
help us to make people
make different choices in ways
that are potentially fairly
cheap and then also in ways
that don't really necessarily
distort behaviors of everyone.
I'm going to get back
to that in a second.
And when it comes to
poverty and mental health,
these are more like
aspects that we say,
if poverty affects
people's decision-making,
it causes behavioral biases,
or low productivity, and so on.
Then things like cash
transfers, [INAUDIBLE]
might help business
[? sincerely. ?] Not sure
that's counts as paternalism.
That's more, like, sort
of support programs.
And then things like
happiness and mental health,
here you would
think about if you
think people are
misoptimizing in certain ways,
they sort of underuse
psychological services,
or if they sort of
misoptimize in various ways,
but we think they could
be experimenting more,
they could be doing more things
to improve their own happiness.
Perhaps there's
some ways in which
you could push people to
experiment more and try
to figure that out.
Notice that I'm sort of
careful here in my wording.
I'm saying "pushing
people to experiment
and trying things out"
as opposed to, like,
pushing people to
do certain things.
For example, if we said
people should be working more
and they work to
more or working less.
And while it's very
hard for the government
to actually understand
what's good and bad,
but it could be that people
are maybe working too much.
And you could sort of
push them towards trying
to think about it.
And then see that, OK, they
want to experiment and sort
of learn more.
Would they perhaps be
happier by doing so?
Any questions on this?
So then there's different
forms of paternalisms
that you can think about.
There's hard paternalism and
there's soft paternalism.
And what's hard paternalism,
essentially forcing choices
on people, changing
prices significantly,
and mandate choices
or procedures,
outlaw products,
including taxes.
So you think of taxes as
sort of changing prices.
You can make things cheaper.
You can make things more
expensive for people.
You can subsidize things.
You can outlaw [INAUDIBLE].
Hard paternalism, if you're
really significantly changing
people's optimization
problem in pretty harsh ways
by essentially changing
prices, potentially
making some options
infinitely expensive.
Right?
It's just to say, look,
I'm just not allowing
you to buy certain goods.
You can think of the price as
just being infinitely expensive
for those goods.
So that's hard paternalism.
Now in contrast, there's other
forms of soft paternalism.
There's two versions of that.
There's what's called the
libertarian paternalism, which
is Thaler and Sunstein
are known for,
which are essentially policies
that constructively influence
behavior while preserving
or nearly preserving freedom
of choice.
But that's essentially
nudges that we
talked about previously.
Essentially, they're saying, you
can choose whatever you want.
But I'm trying to influence
your behavior in some ways that
push you towards some
options or some outcomes
that we think are
better than others.
Right?
Notice that the government,
or the policymaker,
needs to be very clear on
what's good and what's bad.
And then, sort of try
to understand if maybe
here's some good behavior
that we have identified,
let's now try to push you
towards that direction.
But since we're kind of
unsure what people want,
we're not sort of trying
to exclude some options
for some people
because you might
make things worse
for some people,
but instead just try to
push you towards that.
Very much related
to that is what's
called asymmetric paternalism.
This is the term from
Camerer et al., which
are policies that help
people who make mistakes
while interfering minimally with
people who behave optimally.
That is to say, you
want to be careful.
If we see people
doing certain things,
you want to be
careful not to make
things worse for some people.
Suppose there are some people,
for a share of the people,
like, half of the population,
as behavioral agents,
they make a bunch of mistakes.
And half of the population
doesn't make mistakes at all.
Now you could say and
some people are smoking
and some people are not
smoking in each of these.
You might say, well, the
smokers are making mistakes.
The behavioral smokers
are making mistakes.
So let's help them.
So they're going to tax smoking.
Right?
Now what's going to
happen is, well, you
might just improve some
outcomes for those people.
And that might be good.
But there will be other
people who just like smoking.
And they're just happy,
very happy to smoke.
And they know that
there are health risks.
But they decide to smoke anyway.
If you now start to
tax smoking, you're
going to distort their
choices and make things
worse off for them.
So in particular,
asymmetric paternalism
is trying to avoid that by
essentially saying, look,
we will try to come
up with some policies
to make things better
for some people.
But we want to be
very careful not
to make things worse for others,
in particular, people who
are already optimizing, anyway.
OK?
And so libertarian paternalism
is a version of that.
Or it's just very
closely related.
Which is essentially to say, if
you preserve or merely preserve
freedom of choice,
then it often follows
that you're not going
to make things worse
for people optimizing anyway.
Right?
Because if somebody
is optimizing anyway,
and I'm just essentially sort
of providing these small nudges
one way or the
other, then often,
I'm not going to
make things worse
for people optimizing anyway.
That's not necessarily
always the case.
But it's pretty much
closely related.
I'm saying there could be
some people who just smoke--
they have, like, five cigarettes
a day, or one cigarette a day.
And suppose there's
two types of people.
There's one type of
people who are essentially
making mistakes.
They have internalities
in the sense
that they misunderstand
the consequences of smoking
for their future self.
These are people
who make mistakes.
Now those people who
might want to help
by increasing the price
of smoking, by taxing it,
or in other ways.
OK?
But there could be other
people who essentially
are fully aware of the
consequences of smoking
for their future health.
And those are optimizing.
And they're essentially
in the optimization
to decide that smoking
is optimal for them.
Those people might be made
worse off by cigarette taxes.
Because essentially, what
you do, what those taxes are,
any other taxes, you
distort people's behaviors.
And then you have a situation
where we have potentially
made some people better
off, but also other people
are worse off.
And a lot of people would then
be upset or unhappy about this.
Because they say, like, look,
those people who screw up
their choices or they don't
know what they're doing,
we're trying to help them.
But now that comes at
the cost of others who
actually prefer optimizing it.
And in some sense, that
gets you in trouble.
Because there will be unhappy
people on the other side of it,
and potentially,
quite a few of them.
All right.
So what are the arguments
against paternalism?
Or why is paternalism bad?
You might say that
sounds pretty good.
But, like, now, if you try
to actually implement this,
what's bad about it?
So one typical argument
is to say, well,
people make mistakes.
Well, the government
is made out of people.
And so, how do we know
that the people who
run the government actually
know better than people
choose for themselves?
And if the government
is also making mistakes,
then, essentially
choosing for others,
it's not clear that it
makes things better.
Or it could make things worse.
In particular, if you think
that the government doesn't have
enough information.
[INAUDIBLE]
So I know what's best for me.
And so therefore,
I'm best equipped
to make decisions for myself.
It might potentially,
in particular
if there's heterogeneity,
it might make some people
better off.
But that might come at
the cost of some others.
And then it's not clear that
on average or overall making
things better.
[INAUDIBLE] very
important [INAUDIBLE]
in particular that
comes up a lot in 14.75,
for example, which is
Political Economy, that
will come up often.
Because while we might
want to help people,
want to give people
money, but then
the government gets
essentially-- the village
government or whatever gets
captured by elites [INAUDIBLE]
keep the money for themselves.
And so the more, the
more opportunity they
get for that, [INAUDIBLE]
resources and power,
the more opportunity they give
for misuse, and corruption,
and so on, and so forth.
And so that's
essentially saying that--
so this one class up
argument is to say, well,
even if the government wanted
to do the very best for people,
if the government wanted
[INAUDIBLE] for its citizens,
that would be hard to do.
Because it doesn't
know how to do that.
There is inherent problems with
that because of heterogeneity,
knowledge issues, and
so on, and so forth.
And then, there's a
second type of argument,
which Tad just mentioned,
which is, well,
who's there to say that
the government is actually
benevolent and actually wants
people to be better off?
Maybe they just want to get
rich, and so on, and so forth.
And so now, if you
let them make choices,
then that opens the door for
corruption and misuse of money,
and so on, and so forth.
And so there's sort of a
slippery slope argument to say,
well, there's some things
in which I'm going to argue.
For some things,
it's pretty clear
that we can make
things better, or make
some people, at least, better
off without hurting others.
And there's some
cases where you say,
let's have the government
do that or whatever,
but set policies
that help people.
By the way, it
doesn't have to be
necessarily the
government [INAUDIBLE]
company [INAUDIBLE].
But then, [INAUDIBLE] once
we started with, like,
some things, then they're going
to do more and more things.
And at some point,
they'll reach a point
where the government
actually doesn't
know what they're doing.
And then they make
things worse off.
So I have a bunch of
different arguments here.
I think we mentioned
quite a few of them.
There's informational
issues, sort
of not understanding
preferences, people optimizing
anyway.
The comments said, or
we discussed previously,
that some people's choices
might be distorted.
So these are issues of
heterogeneity, often.
Then there's sort of the
government is terrible
and wastes money, anyway.
The government does not
like people's best interests
in mind.
There's regulatory capture.
And there's also what Chad
mentioned, freedom of choice.
Then there are some
other arguments,
which is freedom of
choice matters, per se.
That's a little
trickier to grasp.
But you say, look, it's just
I want to choose for myself.
And I don't want the
government to tell me anything.
And that's important by itself.
This is not about the outcome.
This is about the freedom
of choice mattering itself.
Then similarly, there's
arguments about people just
don't like hard paternalism.
They just don't like to
be told there are, like,
certain options to be
excluded for various reasons.
Perhaps partially because
they don't want the government
to be powerful.
And then, finally,
there is some sort
of practical problems,
which is once we agree
that we want some
paternalistic policies,
which policies should we choose?
And how do we know which
is better than another?
I'm going to get back to
that in a bit as well.
There's also practical
implementation problems,
which is to say even if
the government wanted
to do the right
things, the government
is often inefficient,
and so on, and so forth.
And so it's too costly to do.
And practically, it's just
hard to do certain things.
Now what are arguments in favor?
I'm going to just
speed things up a bit.
So the arguments in favor
are often very simple.
Which is that people make
mistakes, people screw up,
and we can help them
potentially screw up less.
People often also don't
like to necessarily make
choices for themselves.
It could be just because
they don't like doing it.
It could also be just
as costly to do that.
And that's just, there
are some activities
that are just hard to do.
And I'd rather have somebody
regulate this for me,
as opposed to, like,
me having to choose
or make these choices
all for myself.
An example would
be, suppose there's
insurance plans or some
form of retirement plans,
and so on, if there are some
options that are just terrible
and they just would be
exploiting me and making me
worse off, I could
probably figure it out
if you gave me these
plans and I spent, like,
a day studying them.
But you know, I have
better stuff to do.
And I'd rather have somebody
else screen out the bad plans
and sort of then offer me
sort of the choices that
try to not exploit me.
And then, maybe, make some
choices from a limited set.
That's not to say
I couldn't do it.
But it's just sort of
saying it's efficient for me
to try to deal with
these things on my own.
Now, and then finally,
and this is, I think,
one of the most
important arguments,
is that there are a
lot of soft paternalism
regimes where people can opt out
and are unaffected potentially.
So when you go back to
the previous concerns
that people might
have, these are often
arguments against
hard paternalism.
These are often things about
government wasting money,
and so on, and so forth.
If this is about sending
reminders or, like, phrasing
letters in one way versus
another, in some simple way,
or putting food or
putting apples next
to the counter
versus candy bars,
this is not about the government
taking over or restricting
people's free choice.
It's rather to say we're just
trying to make people better
off in some simple ways to do.
And so a lot of these
criticism or arguments
go away once you go into
soft paternalism territory.
And so then, at
the end of the day,
I think it's hard to
make arguments often
for paternalism.
Because you need to be very
confident [INAUDIBLE],, right?
It's much easier to argue
for soft paternalism,
simple policies that
are not expensive,
that arguably are not
hurting a lot of people,
that make at least
some people better off.
And I think-- sorry.
This is a little
hard to see, maybe.
But sometimes it's
actually quite hard
to figure out whether
people are making mistakes.
This is, for example,
a survey from Gallup
that looks at
Americans and looks
at people who call
themselves very or somewhat
overweight versus
the percentage who
are overweight and obese by some
standards by the CDC and so on.
And so here you see
essentially that people
tend to [INAUDIBLE] more obese.
Because the US tends to
be quite high [INAUDIBLE]
increasing people's
perception of that
might be not
necessarily the case.
Now in some ways,
like, who are we
to sort of say that people
should change their behaviors,
or that they're making mistakes?
So in some situations, at
least, it's quite tricky
to figure out what's a
mistake and what's not
and what should we do or not.
And, again, you get
into tricky issues
when it comes to, in
particular, for different selves
and self-control.
Again, who are we
to say that somebody
should lose weight, or
change their behavior
in certain ways, when perhaps
that's not in their best
interest, or that's
not what they're doing.
Maybe they're fully optimizing.
How would we know that
that's not the case?
Now what are some
forms of paternalism
that are quite popular?
There's lots of examples of in
fact for popular paternalism.
There's Social Security.
There's health care
programs for retirees,
including Medicare, which
tends to be quite popular.
There's often restrictions
of investment menus
and 401k savings plans,
where essentially that's
precisely what I
was just saying,
is where essentially just
bad plans and dominated plans
are often just excluded.
There's often consumer safety
regulations that the FDA has
essentially certain
drugs cannot be offered.
You cannot take certain drugs
the government essentially just
sort of [INAUDIBLE] if
they're not being safe.
There's mandatory education.
In many places, you
have to go to school.
You can't just sort of say
I'm just-- sort of my kid
is learning in the forest.
That's not an option.
It often has to
do with protection
of minors in some ways.
Then there's cigarette
taxes, or sin taxes,
as they're often called.
But it's also hard paternalism.
Notice that here, you're
changing people's prices.
In many places, prostitution,
polygamy are banned.
These are like hard bans.
So you're just not allowed
to marry three spouses.
Mandating face masks,
interestingly, that
seems to be-- that's hard
paternalism, as you have,
for example, in Cambridge.
I think that the
punishment is going
to be $300 if you go outside
and don't wear a face mask.
I'm pretty sure in Cambridge
that's quite popular.
Notice, of course, that's not
true in all states, and so on.
So there might be
some policies that
are very much popular
in some places,
but not at all in others.
There's also some
soft paternalism
that tends to be quite popular.
There's some places
where it's not clear
whether it's hard
versus soft paternalism,
or what exactly
the definition is.
Things like banning junk food
in school vending machines,
you can call that sort
of hard paternalism
because you take away
options but of course, it
doesn't really prevent you from
bringing in candy to school
anyway.
So why call that hard
or soft paternalism?
I don't really care.
But that tends to be
quite a popular policy.
Calorie disclosure laws, which
essentially just is saying,
OK, you have to put in some
information for our customers,
which could be easily available.
You could just look it
up online or the like.
And things like default
enrollment and 401(k)
[INAUDIBLE] all tend
to be quite popular.
And for some goods, you
know, there's huge taxes.
For example, cigarette taxes
tend to be extremely high.
This is from 2019.
Notice that there's this
huge variation across places.
If you look at some places here,
these are some of the highest,
such as Connecticut,
including Massachusetts,
it's $3, $4 per
pack of cigarettes.
In addition, there's also like
$1 from the federal government.
Then there's some other
places, including North Dakota,
or North Carolina, and so
on, where cigarette taxes
are extremely low.
So that's kind of
quite interesting,
because it sort of
says, here's a policy
that, depending on your view
of how people make choices,
governments make very
different decisions.
And presumably that has to
do with freedom of choice
or the popularity of that choice
itself in the specific state.
Of course, it also has
to do with, potentially,
the party, and so on.
Similarly, there's also
an aspiration [INAUDIBLE]
state alcohol taxes.
In fact, they vary hugely.
In particular, you
find some states
where the taxes per
gallon are $20, $30,
and some other states where
it's essentially close to 0.
Notice that there's also
a bunch of other blue laws
as they're referred to, which is
things, like, on certain days,
you're not allowed to
sell alcohol, and so on.
Now that's kind of interesting.
Because that's sort of
additional restrictions,
which would tend to be quite
inefficient in various ways.
That is to say, some
economists would
tend to think that if there's
certain behavior that we
don't want people to engage
in, we should tax it.
Instead, you could
essentially sort of outlaw it
in certain ways.
That tends to be
quite inefficient.
Because often, people find
ways to get it anyway.
Plus, the government
does not get
any taxes or revenue from that.
Now what are some unpopular
paternalism or things
that people don't like?
That's exactly it.
One of them is
helmets and seatbelts.
So there, often there's
no externality here.
This is essentially just
something to protect yourself.
While they tend to be quite
unpopular in many places,
it's not quite
clear why that is.
So often, it's sort of
a thing that's not cool,
or like there's some social
norms in some ways where people
think it's not a
thing you want to do.
So I was sort of explaining
to my 14-year-old, 15-year-old
niece to wear a helmet
was sort of very hard.
And then she would
say, yes, yes,
but then drive around, ride
her bike around the corner
and then take it off, and so on.
So that seems to be about
something about personal trade
offs between risk and
reward in some ways
where the government
of some people
might just not value the
benefits of looking cool
or whatever sufficiently, or as
much as the individual itself.
And then they tend to be
sort of unhappy about it.
Of course, the alternative
way of putting this
is that the individual itself
is underestimating the risk
potentially or doesn't take
into account how bad it
would be to actually have a
bicycle accident or the like.
But that's essentially something
about people disagreeing
with the government, or with
their parents, or the like,
about the risk versus
reward and the cost benefits
of certain actions.
And there seems to
be disagreement.
And then you could
sort of mandate that.
But that leads to unhappiness.
Because there's precisely
that disagreement.
Now wearing masks is in
some sense quite similar.
There, it's quite different.
What's different here is that
there's externalities, right?
So the externalities here are
that certain people benefit
a lot from having
their shops open,
or being able to sell things.
And others are affected a lot.
So in particular,
the elderly might
be disproportionately affected
and sort of might essentially--
the number of people who
will die, well, clearly,
if people are not wearing
masks, or if shops,
if people are running
outside, or meeting,
and so on, and so forth.
But there's others
who are really--
for them, that's really costly.
Because their businesses
are not open and the like.
Now there could be
entirely rational issues
where you might say,
well, people just
don't care about certain
other groups of the society.
And therefore, you want
to have your shop open.
And you don't want to be told
that you should be doing that.
There could be also mistakes
in the sense that people just
don't understand, necessarily,
there are these externalities.
They might sort of say,
well, I'm not affected.
And I'll be just fine.
And it might be, actually,
that the risk for themselves
is not that high.
But of course, there's large
externalities in others
that they might not appreciate
or not take into account.
Exactly.
So Chad, Carmen is saying
speed limits, similarly,
are similar to that.
Because it's sort of,
like, I'm driving.
But there's [INAUDIBLE]
in certain accidents.
And so why is that?
Or so how do we think
about [INAUDIBLE] say?
So I mentioned here,
this is an example.
So here we have [INAUDIBLE]
are quite popular.
And why is that popular?
And why is making certain drugs
illegal, why is that unpopular?
What's the problem there?
So I think there's,
when you think about,
when you do, like,
economic analysis of that,
is [INAUDIBLE] you can think
this might be externality.
Externalities might
actually be much lower
than for smoking or drinking.
Because drunk driving
and so on is very lethal.
There might be also
some externalities
from smoking weed.
But the externalities
[INAUDIBLE]
are for drinking, well, then
there could be [INAUDIBLE]
But, again, for internalities,
usually the solution
would be just the typical
sin taxes, and so on.
You can say, well, do
you want to tax it.
Sure.
But then you at least
would get some revenue.
You would increase the price.
You would get some revenue
for the government,
plus you would lower
people's consumption.
In addition, there's all this
stuff about locking people up
unnecessarily.
By making it illegal,
essentially we
create a large
prisoner population,
and so on, which surely
is [INAUDIBLE] society.
So once you sort of have
this policy [INAUDIBLE],,
there's actually
not a lot of reasons
for outlawing how
these sort of tend
to be gut reactions or
some sort of judgments
that were made at some point.
And there's some lobby
arguing in favor of alcohol
and maybe less of a lobby
arguing for other drugs.
But as we say, the sentiment
has very much changed.
And it seems to me, sooner
or later, pretty much
all states are moving
towards legalization
and that leads to, essentially,
[INAUDIBLE] government
revenues as well.
So I think one argument
perhaps that one could make
is sort of these
gateway-drug arguments, which
I don't think there's actually
that much evidence for that.
But you say, well, actually,
marijuana might not
be so bad by itself,
but perhaps it
leads to other
[? worries. ?] It's not
obvious at all that
legalization of that-- so A,
it's not obvious that that's
necessarily true, but B,
it's not obvious that making
it legal versus illegal changes
that rationale.
Because when it's
illegal, lots of people
are using drugs anyway.
And maybe it makes it
even more [INAUDIBLE]
and maybe more
dangerous, potentially.
But I think it's
important to realize
that some of these policies
are very much, in some ways,
arbitrary, based on some
legacy or some lobbies
and so on and so forth.
And what's important
here is then
that the popularity
itself then also will
affect policies in some way.
So like, [INAUDIBLE],,
as you say,
the public sentiment has
shifted in various [INAUDIBLE]
some ways stuff will become
legal as a result of that.
And once you do it in some
states and things seem fine
and the states make a
lot of money from it,
a lot of other states eventually
will follow suit, in part
because it's also much
harder to enforce laws
if you have a bunch
of surrounding states
where you can buy stuff legally.
And that makes it, of
course, trickier, then,
to enforce the law anyway.
I have some other unpopular
examples [INAUDIBLE]
unpopular-- paternalism, junk
food bans, junk food taxes.
And some of these things,
again, are changing over time.
So it may well be that
things are different
in 10, 20 years from now.
Gambling laws, pornography
laws, other kinds of sin taxes.
Mandating face masks--
and again, in some states,
they're just really,
really popular.
And people are on the
streets protesting
against it, which is quite
interesting [INAUDIBLE]
might be.
But often it is the case that
there are some forms of--
that there's real economic
interest behind that, often.
And perhaps,
[? so ?] again, that
could be very much
fully rational
and could also be that
people might misunderstand
the externalities
that are at play.
There's some other kinds
of hard paternalism that's
also kind of unpopular and
also not a particularly
efficient thing to
do, which is things
like the ban on
16-ounce sodas, which
is kind of like a weird thing
to do if you think about it,
because you can just
buy smaller bottles
or the like, which tends to
be quite inefficient overall.
Here's a sign for seatbelts.
Now, OK, so here's
the legalization,
which also there is massive
variation across states.
Now, there's some nudges.
And some policies
have massive impacts.
And we studied at
least some of this.
For example, this was
automatic enrollment.
There is essentially a
huge swing towards that.
Essentially lots of companies
and so on are now using that.
And the fraction of people who
are participating in retirement
plans is way higher than
the fraction of people when
there's voluntary [INAUDIBLE].
There's other policies which
are quite simple policies which
are things trying to get
people to appear in court.
So essentially
lots of people who
have to appear in court for,
like, initial court hearings
tend to not show up
in those meetings.
And as you can imagine,
that's not a great idea.
Because that essentially leads
to really bad consequences.
Now, what you can
essentially just do
is try to do very
simple policies.
And there's a very nice paper
by [INAUDIBLE] and others
that looks at this.
You can sort of
change the forms.
You can phrase
things differently.
That essentially tries to nudge
people in the right direction.
You can also do things like
text message reminders.
And the text message literally
just says, your court date
is on May 22 at 9:00 AM.
Please show up.
And you remind
people to do that,
and what you get
essentially is that you
get large decreases in
timely court appearances--
or non-appearances, or
the fraction of people
who don't show up in court,
to their own court hearing,
decreases a lot by using
very, very simple policies.
Once you do those kinds
of policies, presumably,
[INAUDIBLE] not much to
say against this policy
in the sense that you
might say, well, so A,
you're not restricting
anybody's choices.
You're also not really
making anybody worse
off by sending some
text message reminders.
There might be some
small inconveniences
of receiving these
text messages, which
are kind of annoying and
spam for some people.
But overall, nobody's
really made off by this.
It's a very cheap thing to do.
So there's not a
lot of arguments
against such policies,
where you say, look,
here's a policy that's
extremely cheap to do.
Some people are benefiting.
Presumably showing up in
court is a good thing--
for your court hearing.
And it's cheap thing to do.
And the benefits are
potentially large.
Because now we
prevent some people
from essentially
ending up in jail
for too long or for
unnecessary time
because they failed to
appear to their hearings.
But so then I think
it's also important--
so there's some examples that
essentially show large effects,
including automatic
enrollment, including things
like text messages
of some interventions
to induce court appearances.
But it's important to understand
that not everything always
works.
What you see often,
or what I've shown
you are examples of successful
examples of stuff that works.
But there are some examples
that just don't work at all.
So here's an example of a
clinical trial, which is called
the HeartStrong
randomized clinical trial,
which gave people
essentially a kitchen
sink of things that we think
are all good things to do.
This is stuff like
[? reminders, ?]
financial incentives,
social support,
and so on and so forth,
for people, essentially,
who had heart attacks,
by giving them
wireless bottles, lottery-based
incentives, and again,
social support, having friends
and family to help them.
And essentially that did
exactly nothing for people
and had no effect whatsoever.
So it's not to say that we
think everything works, always,
and we should just always nudge
people and provide incentives
and so on and so forth.
And something that might
work but in fact there's
no reason to think that
it might always work.
In some situations, this might
be helpful and others not.
More concerningly there's
also a very recent paper
from Stefano DellaVigna that
just came out like a week ago
that looks at academic
studies and nudge units.
That's to say what
they're trying
to do is look at treatment
effects in academic studies
that are published in
papers which are papers
like the stuff that we
saw on default effects
and so on, which is Carroll et
al is the 401(k) savings one,
here is the study on FAFSA
involvement that I showed you,
there's some
changing many orders
in buffet line for
healthier food consumption.
So there's a bunch of
papers that usually you
would teach in a typical class.
And what you see here
is, on the y-axis,
you could see treatment
effects and percentage points.
On the x-axis here you see
the control group tick up,
which is to say, if
you don't do anything,
what does the control group do?
And what do you see is
pretty large effects
in many of these studies
that are published.
There are some questions on this
is like U-shaped or inverse U
or whatever.
Let's ignore that for a second.
But overall what you see is
pretty large treatment effects
in these situations.
And this is like 26 trials
and 71 different nudges here.
When you instead look
at nudge units-- so
what are nudge units?
These are essentially,
for example,
the UK government has what's
called the BIT, the Behavioral
Insights Team, which essentially
is a team inside the UK
government that tries to
support or nudge people
to make better choices.
And that's very much coming
from the nudge movement,
from Thaler and so on,
that sort of advised the UK
government to set this up.
And they're now nudging away.
Because the government is really
happy about cheap stuff that
doesn't cost very much but
potentially has large benefits.
Now what they then
also do, often,
is they evaluate their
interventions in part
because they try to figure
out what works best.
Now, when you look at
these interventions,
you see essentially that
the treatment effects
in those kinds of
interventions tend
to be much larger
than on the left.
If you at the right,
there's a bunch
of stuff, a massive bunch of
points that are pretty high,
above 10%, 20%.
When you look to the
right, essentially you
see almost everything
is between 0% and 10%.
A lot of it seems to be not
statistically significantly
different from 0.
So that should give us some
pause in the sense of we
should be careful in necessarily
recommending a bunch of stuff
to government and saying
we should always nudge
and so on and so forth.
What's going on here?
Well, some of this could
be about publication bias.
Essentially there's a bunch
of studies that are being run,
and what's being
published is essentially
stuff that's highly significant
and flashy and important.
There could be also issues
with implementation,
that maybe what's
done with researchers
is sort of implemented
better, potentially,
and maybe what's
done at scale is
just harder to do in nudge units
and harder to do carefully.
And then the effects
might be lower.
Not to say that
governments shouldn't
nudge in a sense of,
if there are effects
of the order of magnitude
something like 5%,
percentage points, and
that's really cheap to do,
you should probably
do it anyway.
But it's just the same, nudges
are not the magic bullet
that sort of change
everything and the government
should always engage on them.
And it's quite
important, in fact,
for the governments,
or governments,
or any sort of
these policy units.
And firms, by the way,
do the exact same thing
to try and figure out what
works and what doesn't, and not
just rely on the academic
evidence that might sort of be
more proof-of-concept rather
than sort of something that
evaluates cost-effectiveness.
Any questions on this?
Now, another question--
this is a little blurry--
another question you
might ask, and you
might have seen these
kinds of letters
before, whether everybody
wants to be nudged.
And so what there's a very
famous study by Allcott
and others that looked
at energy comparisons.
It's a study done with Opower,
the company, that essentially
tries to reduce energy usage.
And the way this
works is what you do
is you send people
these kinds of letters.
And I'm getting these letters
too that sort of say, here's
your energy consumption in
the last month, the last year.
Here is all of your neighbors.
So it's your comparisons.
You see the blue bar is
like how much did you use
and the gray bar
is like how much
did all of your neighbors use.
And then there's
the green bar that
sort of says how much do
efficient neighbors use.
And then there's smileys, where
you have two smileys if you're
doing great, one smiley
if you're doing good,
like this fellow here.
And then there's
no smiley, I guess,
if you're not doing well.
Sometimes there's
also like a sad smiley
if you're using lots
of energy and so on.
And so then essentially
what this is trying to do
is trying to provide some
social comparison here.
It's a very cheap policy to do.
In particular, when you're
sending energy bills anyway,
it's very cheap to add this
at the top, where essentially
you're sending people
energy bills anyway.
And now you're adding
this social comparison
to try to nudge people
to use less energy.
There's a question of why
the company might do that.
But that's a separate issue.
And what you see here is, when
you look at treatment effects,
there tends to be clearer
treatment effects--
at least some treatment
effects of providing
those kinds of information
reduces overall energy
consumption in RCTs
that people have.
Now, one question you might
ask is, well, shouldn't we
then always do this?
So what's the reason
not to do that?
And it turns out [INAUDIBLE] not
everybody wants to be nudged.
So here's an intervention
where now, again,
Allcott and co-author
have now, in fact,
asked people about, would you
like to receive these letters
or would you like to
receive these kinds
of social comparisons?
And what they ask is what's
your positive willingness
to pay for it.
So would you like to have a
dollar, versus these reports?
So a dollar and
no reports versus
just receiving the reports.
What is people's
willingness to pay?
But they also ask
their willingness
to pay not to receive
these reports.
That is to say, I
could either tell you--
I would ask you, you receive
zero dollars and no reports
or you receive a
dollar and the reports.
And some people turn that
down, which essentially
implies that they'd rather have
a dollar less and no reports.
They're willing to pay
not to receive reports.
And this is what you
see here on the left,
is essentially
people's willingness
to pay for home reports.
So there are quite
a few people here
on the right who have
positive willingness to pay.
They think it's kind of useful,
it's kind of interesting.
Maybe it helps them
reduce energy consumption.
Maybe that motivates
them in certain ways.
But some people are just
saying, essentially,
I do not want these reports.
And the reason being
that, essentially, it's
kind of just annoying to
get nagged all the time.
Maybe in some cases you just
don't have a lot of choice.
And in some cases maybe you
just like to use lots of energy
for whatever reason.
And it's really annoying
to be told all the time
that your neighbor is
really better than you are.
It makes people
uncomfortable and makes them
unhappy and so on and so forth.
Maybe it makes them feel guilty.
Who knows?
Maybe they just don't
want to think about it.
But importantly, there
are some people who
just do not want to be nudged.
And I think that's important.
Because when you think
back about the libertarian
paternalism or the soft
paternalism criteria,
asymmetric paternalism
that we talked about, well,
what the asymmetric
paternalism would say
is we should not make
anybody worse off.
So now if we send
all these letters
and make, actually,
people uncomfortable,
then in fact we are potentially
making people worse off.
And you can think about some
other types of interventions.
If you [INAUDIBLE] letters
from MIT all the time,
how are you doing
compared to classmates,
in terms of study efforts,
in terms of problem sets,
[INAUDIBLE] and so on,
potentially that would likely
increase study efforts in some
ways and would perhaps increase
learning in some ways.
But it's not clear at all that
we would increase welfare.
Because maybe everybody
would be even more
stressed and everybody
would sort of
be less happy and so on and so
forth, at least in some cases.
Yeah, actually so Jenna
is asking a question
about who's unhappy about this.
So the asymmetric
paternalism is just
to say suppose there are
some people who are just very
happy with their choice
about using a lot of energy,
and they just don't
want to be nudged.
They're fully rationally
choosing this.
Maybe they know, deep
down in their heart,
that it's bad to ruin the planet
and climate and so on and so
forth.
But they really made
a choice that they
want to use lots of energy.
Those people are
not the people who
want to receive any letters.
So asymmetric paternalism
would say we should just
leave them alone.
They should just be doing
whatever they want to do.
And us sending them letters
to make them feel bad
if they don't even change
their behavior anyway,
or even if they would
change their behavior,
that's not for us to say.
And we should just
leave them alone
because we make them worse
off by receiving these letters
by their revealed preference
to say they are willing to pay
not to receive these letters.
Now, there could be some
situations where people
who have potentially
large treatment effects,
these are people who
use lots of energy
and they just don't
know about it.
And those, you want
to sort of send them
letters and push them.
But I think the whole point
of the asymmetric paternalism
is to say we shouldn't
make anybody worse off.
So if somebody reveals to us,
by their preference, which
is what these fellows are
doing here, that they really
don't want to receive
these letters,
we should respect that.
And then one potential
solution here
is to say, well, why don't
we just let people opt out,
where you just say, OK, you
send people these letters.
And then you have to
click on something
or you have to opt in or out.
And then maybe people
who really don't
want to receive these letters,
we can essentially just let
them be.
There's no judgment
here in terms
of is that socially
what we want to do
and is this a good
or a bad thing,
this is just to say we should
respect people's preferences
in certain ways.
Does that make sense?
Now the next question
you might ask
is, well, what form
should paternalism take?
And that's the thing,
since it's important,
because you could take
401(k) savings policies,
you can come up with a
lots of different options
with which you could design
your 401(k) savings policies.
You could have active decisions.
You can have defaults
for participation.
You have defaults for
all this information.
You have a personal financial
planner sitting down with you.
You might have a minimum
amount of-- this is,
I guess, hard paternalism--
minimum amount
of non-zero 401(k) savings
rate, which is just force people
to save.
And it's important to say it's
not just about paternalism
versus non-paternalism.
Once you get into the
paternalism realm,
it's actually very
hard to figure out
what should we do
because there's
so many different options.
And it's hard to tell which
one is better than the other.
More generally, even,
it's actually quite hard
to come up with any
non-paternalism option.
That is to say, think of all
the options that are there.
In some sense, once you
think that defaults affect
people's decisions,
then no savings default
is also a form of paternalism.
In some sense you say, you
choose something for people,
and that's going to
push them to not, say,
fully choose [INAUDIBLE]
like there's nothing special
about the zero [INAUDIBLE] also
have a 10% savings default.
And so it's important
to understand,
regardless of what
choice you choose,
you're going to affect people's
choices and their behaviors
in certain ways.
And so that's what it
means, essentially, that
have to take a stance in which
you affect people's behavior.
In a way, just saying we're just
choosing a zero savings default
is in some sense a cop-out.
Because even the
zero savings default
is affecting people's
behavior quite a bit.
So in a way, the discussion
should rather be about what is
the optimal way or the optimal
paternalism-- soft paternalism,
I would argue--
rather than saying
paternalism versus not.
Because regardless of
what option you choose,
you're going to affect
behaviors in certain ways
because precisely the way
you provide information
to people on their
default frames, et cetera,
affect people's choices.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So here's a very quick example
of a very useful and helpful
example of libertarian
paternalism
that has been quite successful.
So Thaler and
Benartzi were asked
to design a 401(k) savings for a
company that wanted to increase
its employees' savings.
So the company hired
a financial advisor.
The employees could sit
down with the advisor
to evaluate their financial
situation and make a plan.
So for those who agreed to talk
to the advisor, the advisor--
he, I guess, in this case--
recommended a savings rate.
Some agreed to implement this.
And then Benartzi and
Thaler got the leftovers.
So that's arguably a
group that's negatively
selected towards saving a lot.
Now, what's then the SMarT--
the Save More Tomorrow-- plan?
Employees were then
approached about increasing
their contribution rate
a considerable time
before the next
scheduled pay raise.
So that's to say, before the
next scheduled pay raise,
they were essentially asked
about whether they would
like to join
voluntarily and if they
wanted to do their
contribution to the plan
was going to be
increased beginning
with the first paycheck
after the raise.
So that's to say, I told
you, in December, you're
going to get a pay
raise, would you
like to increase your
contribution then
once you receive that pay raise?
And so then you could
choose a preset maximum.
And then what would happen
is the contribution rate
would automatically increase
over time with each pay raise
that you would receive.
Suppose your pay raise
is like, say, 5% or 3%,
what you would
get then is like--
and suppose it's 3%.
You would get only a 2% increase
in your pay and 1% or 1%
percentage point of
your pay would then
go towards the
retirement contribution.
Importantly, the
employee can opt out
of the plan at any point in
time by essentially just making
a phone call or the like.
Now, why is this plan a
libertarian paternalism?
Well because of aspects 2 and 4.
It's voluntary.
So you can do whatever you want.
You don't have to
choose this at all.
You can essentially decline it.
You can also opt out
at any point in time.
So arguably nobody
is made worse off.
Because essentially
what we're doing here
is increasing people's
options by saying,
here's an option for you
to increase your saving
automatically over time.
And you can leave it whenever
you would like to do.
So arguably nobody should
be worse off by this.
And potentially some people are
made better off quite a bit.
And that's exactly
what you see here.
Essentially, when you
look at the people who
joined the SMarT plan--
notice that this
is not random here.
So there's some concerns
about an indication.
But setting that aside, if you
look at the people who, again,
arguably, are
negatively selected,
these are people who declined
the financial consultant,
they essentially increased
their savings dramatically
as a consequence
of this SMarT plan.
And now the SMarT plan has
been introduced or implemented
in quite a few places.
But anyway, that's
not the point here.
I want to say what's
good about the plan is,
well, it's a SMarT plan not just
because of the acronym but also
because it's using behavioral
principles or stuff
that you learned in class
quite a bit and carefully.
So what are these principles?
So why is this a
useful plan to use?
And I'm going to show you
again what the plan is.
What's clever about this plan?
What is it using carefully?
By the way, I don't know if you
can hear this background noise.
My neighbor has engaged in
various home improvement
projects since the quarantine.
I have so far refrained
from complaining about it
because I don't know what's
going on in their lives
otherwise.
And maybe that's a way
of dealing with stress
and so on, if you can hear this.
Once you opt in, the default
is for the contribution rate
to increase.
So the default is essentially
working towards increasing
people's safety.
So there's two
things going on here.
One is present bias, when you
say, well, yeah, in the future,
I want to save more.
So precisely that's
kind of great.
Because now the future self
will be virtuous and so on.
So if people have present
bias, that will help.
And then there's
also the part that's
about paycheck increases.
Remember, people tend
to be loss-averse.
So what this plan is
also accomplishing is,
so if I'm asking you
right now, today,
would you like to increase your
savings rate, well, not only
are you present-biased,
but also you're
going to have a cut
in your paycheck.
And people hate cuts
in their paychecks.
So instead, it's saying,
well, in the future,
your raise will be lower.
And people are less averse
to reducing those increases
compared to
experiencing pay cuts.
So that's, I think,
what we have here.
So this essentially
present bias is helping.
Then there's
reference dependence.
And then there's defaults
that help people switching out
of some form of present bias,
where precisely as we said
previously, people
are not switching out
of those kinds of plans.
So if you think
that's a good thing
to increase people's
savings, here that's
[INAUDIBLE],, because
people might actually
procrastinate
switching out of it
once they're in in
the first place.
So that seems to
be a great example.
Because not only is it
preserving people's free choice
and not making people
worse off, but also it's
using, in a smart way,
behavioral principles.
Let me briefly talk
about the market.
And we talked about this a
little bit already previously,
but I want to make
this explicit.
So one argument that often
comes in particular out
of [INAUDIBLE] is,
well, if people have
self-control problems
or other issues, well,
will not the market come up with
some goods or some solutions
that will help people?
After all, there's
money to be made
in improving people's choices.
So if, really, self-control
problems or the like
are really important,
why is not anybody
coming up with a market solution
and a great product that
helps people?
And then they're going to make
a lot of money from doing so.
And so particularly if
consumers are sophisticated
and they demand ways to
change the consumption,
and then there will be somebody
who is providing that good.
And if the welfare
effects of those kinds
of self-control or other
distortions are large,
then you can make a lot
of money from helping
people improve their behavior.
So what's problematic with
this line of argument?
Well, the market is precisely
part of the problem.
So on the one hand,
you can say, if you
try to-- so if you Google--
and this is quite a while ago,
but right now it's, in some
sense, more sophisticated ways
and there's lots of
targeting going on.
But if you Google impulsive
credit-card spending, what
you're going to get
is a bunch of advice
to help you with that.
But at the same time, you also
get a bunch of credit card
offers or you're going to
get targeted eventually
by companies that try to
precisely exploit you.
So on the one
hand, there will be
a side of the market who
will potentially help you,
but there's another
side of the market who
will want to exploit you.
And importantly, what
the market will do
is firms will try to
target naive people.
And you might remember
this from lectures 5 and 6.
But essentially
firms precisely try
to find people who are perhaps
less sophisticated financially
in other ways.
So the firms are precisely
trying to target naive people.
Because those are the
people you can exploit.
Moreover, the naive are
the ones who will think,
well, I don't have any
problems, so I don't actually
need any goods or any sort of
products that might help you.
So not only are
they being targeted
by people who try
to screw them over,
but also they actually
are reluctant to seek help
because precisely they're
naive and they think it's not
even necessary to seek help.
So even a firm who wants to
help has trouble making money
with this.
Because people,
if they're naive,
will not necessarily understand
that help is required.
And that's precisely the tension
that we see in many markets,
where there's some
firms who might want
to help and support-- in
this case, self-control,
but it's also true
for other issues.
But there's, on the
other side, firms
that try to break down the
self-control from consumers
precisely because they can make
a bunch of money from that.
And so now the second
part, "severely limits
the market's ability to
provide self-control,"
because it essentially
[INAUDIBLE]..
Now, the government of course
can try to address this.
And this is what behavioral
IO would be about.
Behavioral IO would
be about saying--
Industrial Organization,
which would
be there's behavioral
consumers, there's
firms who try to
exploit consumers.
Now the government
is trying to support,
or by some form of regulation,
trying to help customers,
in particular things like the
Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau and so on trying
to help consumers not
to get exploited by banning
advertising, by capping
interest rates, and
so on and so forth,
but also by, for example,
mandating disclosure
and so on and so forth.
Now I'm going to say one final
thing about nudges, which is,
on the one hand, we
talk about nudges
in a sense of saying
that, look, there's
some behavior that
we're trying to improve,
which would be like suppose
people keep forgetting
certain things, to
take their medication
or to appear in court.
Let's send reminders
to improve behaviors.
We can set defaults in certain
ways and so on and so forth,
which is policies to improve
good behaviors, assuming
that the person who
makes those choices
is benevolent in certain ways.
Now, on the other
hand, of course,
firms can use the
same techniques
on the same approaches
to do the exact opposite
and so to harm people.
And this is what Thaler and
Sunstein called sludges, which
essentially is like using
these nudges in bad ways
by trying to push people
in wrong directions.
So an example of that would be
offering rebates on a product
and then having customers
required to mail in forms
and to, like-- and you
may have encountered these
and wondered why I have
to mail in this form.
And this is kind of tedious.
And then you end
up not doing it.
[INAUDIBLE] want
you to think, oh,
I'm getting this great discount,
and then actually never send it
in because then they don't
have to actually pay you.
They can sell you the
good, but then they
don't have to give you the
discount at the end of the day.
So there's a bunch
of types of cases,
both on the private sector but
also from the public sector,
such as things as
voter registration.
When you think about it,
why is voter registration
harder in certain places?
Well, the reason why it's hard
is because certain parties
and groups do not want certain
types of groups of people
to vote.
And those are essentially
deliberate ways
of making it hard for people to
make choices that aren't really
good for them or for society.
And that's what Thaler and
Sunstein would call sludges.
And then here it's
important to realize
that it's, in fact,
identifying and eliminating
such judges, which essentially
are certain ways that
make it hard for people to make
good choices for themselves
and for society, can be
equally important or perhaps as
important as sort of
implementing nudges
to improve people's
behavior in certain ways.
So it's not just
about taking behavior
where people, on their own,
screw up in certain ways
and trying to improve them
and trying to help them,
but rather helping people being
misdirected in certain ways
to be exploited.
And in many cases, in
particular in companies,
identify those kinds of sludges
and calling companies out
gets you pretty
far, in some sense,
on social media and the like.
Once called out,
companies often back down
and try to reduce
them because they
don't want to have bad
reputations of exploiting
customers.
OK, so let me sort of summarize
the lecture and then briefly,
in two minutes, the whole class.
So some forms of, in
particular, soft paternalism
can unambiguously
improve welfare.
And we should be quite
excited about that.
And they can help quite a bit.
Now, on the other hand, nudges
can also make things worse.
And particularly
if the government
doesn't know what's
good for people and we
want to be careful in nudging.
And there's some examples
[INAUDIBLE] in class.
But there's also some examples
of nudges actually backfiring.
Now, in addition to that, some
people dislike being nudged.
And we should respect that
and take that into account.
We try to maximize utility,
remember, as opposed
to certain behaviors or
take-up of certain outcomes.
And you want to be careful
not to make people worse off.
And helping people opt
out of certain nudges
or certain [? interventions ?]
should be quite helpful.
In addition, the market
does not solve everything.
So we should not have faith
in the market solving things.
In particular, the market
might make things worse.
And finally, reducing
sludges can go a long way
in improving behavior overall.
Now, the big-picture
summary of this class,
what is it, in one slide, that
I want you to take away and have
learned?
Of course, things
are more complicated.
But let me give you
a very brief summary.
So one, psychological
considerations
can be quite important in
a lot of economic choices
and behaviors.
And we should take
them very seriously.
For you, personally, I think
that means, in some ways,
understanding your own biases
and mistakes and issues better
and try to improve
decision-making.
It seems quite important.
That's true for short-run or
simple sort of considerations,
such as how to deal
with procrastination
and exercising and so on.
It's also true for long-run
considerations like which
jobs you want to have, what
friends do you want to keep,
and so on and so forth.
It could make you
[? both happy ?]
or unhappy in the future.
And you want to be quite
mindful about that.
Small changes or thinking
about things for a while
can make big differences.
So I very much encourage
you to introspect,
be more mindful or
mindful in your choices.
As I said last time,
experimenting, seeking advice,
including psychological
support and so on,
seem to be quite helpful.
At the same time, you also
shouldn't stress too much
and just try to be happy and
don't be too harsh on yourself.
Often, people are doing
quite well already overall.
It's also worth understanding
that sometimes it's
actually easier to
help your friends
or others than yourself.
It's often easier
to see, in others,
how they're misoptimizing and
how to improve their behaviors.
So in some ways,
helping others might
be, in fact one of the things
you might have taken away
from this class.
And then, finally, you
want to think about,
in particular, when you
think about designs of teams,
working with others,
incentives, products,
and so on, if you try to
design an app or any website
or [INAUDIBLE],, thinking about
psychological considerations
and designing things
[INAUDIBLE] is quite important
that you should [INAUDIBLE]
take those things into account.
Somebody is asking
about books to read.
So I just added them here.
I was planning to say
a little bit more,
but I'm out of time so I'm
just leaving this here.
I'll try to add a couple of
sentences for each [INAUDIBLE]..
There's some quite amazing
books that you can read.
In particular, for example,
Cialdini's '93 Influence book
is an amazing book to read.
Then Ariely has
really nice books,
including Predictably
Irrational.
And some of these are
more basic than others.
But if you're
interested in poverty,
Mullainathan and
Shafir's Scarcity book
is really an amazing read.
And then Danny
Kahneman's Thinking,
Fast and Slow is also extremely
insightful and interesting.
Of course there's other books,
for example, Dick Thaler talks
about the history of
behavioral economics,
Lewis is what's called
The Undoing Project, which
is about Kahneman,
first his friendship,
and how they sort of
essentially came to,
in some really important
ways, revolutionizing
some parts of economics.
So there's lots
of things to read.
If you're interested in any
of these, just let me know.
I'm very happy to chat.
So that's pretty much
all I have to say.
I had lots of fun
teaching this class.
I know this semester was tricky
and difficult for many of us.
Every time I teach this class,
I'm surprised how much I learn.
I hope you learned
something useful things too.
I guess this is from last time.
So there's no course
evaluations this year.
We might do an informal
one to just [INAUDIBLE]
try to learn more
about what you thought.
We did already an
informal evaluation,
but that's assuming that there
would be actual evaluations
this semester.
Unfortunately, MIT has
canceled them this year,
I think to be mindful
for some people who
are particularly affected
by the quarantine and so on.
Come to my office hours
if you have questions.
I have some Europe
opportunities.
Some of you have already
applied for those.
There's been quite
a bit of interest.
So if you have already applied,
I'll get back to you soon.
But any case, come and talk
to me if you're interested.
I hope you learn more economics
in the future [INAUDIBLE]
help you take psychological
considerations
in those economic
issues quite seriously.
So thank you very much.